He was by her side throughout the longest reign of a monarch in British history.
For Prince Philip, Duke of Edinburgh, it wasn't only a marriage,...
...but a life of service to his wife, Queen Elizabeth II.
Born into Greek and Danish royalty, Philip had a lonely childhood.
He was taken under the wing of the British aristocracy.
When he married the then Princess Elizabeth in 1947,...
...he was a promising young naval officer.
It was a fairytale wedding for a country emerging from war and hardship.
It all changed for the young couple when Elizabeth's father, King George VI,...
...died at only 56 years of age.
She became Queen.
And so began life in the Queen's shadow.
Hundreds of engagements a year,...
...he did, however, manage to find time for his own charities,...
...helping young people and conserving wildlife.
His retirement from public duties came in 2017...
...with a send-off from the Royal Marines.
Whatever the faults, his 60 years of public service was admired by many people.
While their marriage was said to have had its ups and downs...
...in the couple's younger years,...
...Prince Philip remained dedicated and supportive to the Queen.
She'll receive immense sympathy from a British public...
...known to view her with respect and affection.